Christiane's trace their origins to a
Jew named Jesus who lived and preached
about the kingdom of God under the Roman
Empire in the 1st century CE II Jesus
left no writings but his followers wrote
many Gospels letters and apocalyptic
books that claim he is the son of God
and the promised Jewish Messiah the
Christ Christians also accept a
collection of Jewish Scriptures
containing divine law prophecy songs
prayers love poetry and narratives of
God's actions these scriptures teach
that God created the world and humanity
and goodness yet the first humans Adam
and Eve disobeyed God he punished them
with suffering and death but he also
showed great mercy God chose Israel to
be his people and a light to the
nation's
he gave the divine law to Moses and sent
prophets to call people to righteousness
and joy Christian's appropriated and
interpreted these Jewish writings as
prophecy of the coming of the Messiah
Jesus letters written by Paul and his
companions taught that Jesus's death and
resurrection fulfilled God's plan for
the eternal salvation
later followers wrote stories of Jesus's
life and teachings in books called
Gospels they proclaimed Jesus as the
co-creator of the world the child of a
virgin named Mary a divine prophet
teacher healer and miracle worker
he called on people to repent and turn
to the kingdom of God the greatest
Commandments he taught are to love God
with one's whole heart mind and strength
and to love one's neighbor as oneself in
the end he was caught up in local
political tensions and crucified by the
Romans outside of Jerusalem the Bible
teaches that God raised him from the
dead and he appeared to his disciples
before his final ascent to God
commissioning them to spread his
teachings to the ends of the earth it
claims he will return at the end of time
and usher in the final judgment granting
eternal bliss to believers and eternal
torment to all others the apocalypse
tells of the final battles and the
creation of a new heaven and our
from its inception at the crossroads of
three continents Asia Africa and Europe
Christianity spread around the
Mediterranean Sea north to Germany and
Britain west from Greece to Spain from
Egypt along the African coast and south
to Ethiopia east through Syria to India
and beyond in 16th century Europe a set
of movements tied to new political and
social developments assured in the
Protestant Reformation at the same time
Christian missionaries accompanied
European expansion to every corner of
the globe following the tracks of empire
trade and colonization European
Christians played many roles sometimes
complicit in the exploitation and
oppression of colonized peoples
sometimes colonialism's strongest
critics sometimes themselves fleeing
religious violence and seeking to
establish safe places to practice their
faith new forms of Christian belief and
practice were established in North and
South America throughout Asia Australia
and the Pacific shaped by local
languages cultures and histories
although this diversity is often
represented by religious leaders and
theologians or described in terms of its
main institutional or theological forms
Roman Catholicism Eastern Orthodoxy
Protestantism and Pentecostalism they
don't tell the whole story the lived
practice of Christians includes local
forms of art architecture and music
celebrating holidays and rituals
practices of personal prayer and
devotion people of all classes races
genders and walks of life comprise the
richness of Christianity
[Music]